y'all got to see it it's really good you
know who's got the hardest job tonight
javier beldem and his wife are both
nominated
now if she loses he can't win
he is praying that will spend wednesday
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay
so we are here
to uh give a documentary out to give an
oscar out for best documentary
[Music]
you know i was thinking when i have seen
the unedited version [ __ ] having a
tough set give me two seconds
give me two seconds
give me two seconds
well
well
well
well
what you did man was assault
you and i
both know
that when [ __ ] talk about your
wife you have to wait for them to
challenge you into a boxing match
and then you accept
and you wait for them to [ __ ] out
weren't you mohammed ali
i'ma say this bro
you guys think this is real this is just
season four if everybody hates chris
yes everybody really does um listen it
was a joke it was a joke it was a joke
okay go go ahead go ahead go ahead okay
go ahead you guys don't know who jay
jane jay james the ball
she bald
way jada bald if you aren't aware jada
has alopecia apparently yeah i was not
aware of so that's why she balled she
didn't seem to like the joke
will smith took some exception to it
there you guys have it do i think this
is real it looked real to me it was real
it would look it was
the way he messed up the next thing i
mean if it's not if it's not real i will
say chris rock the way his head reel
back like that liz i've seen a lot of
punches in my life that should look very
real anyways all that to say
um i understand it was a joke but you
have to understand that there's so much
a man can take now ever since that
happened that didn't happen with jada
and everything and stuff
even will said it himself that there was
no cheating involved right we made jokes
we i say we we
we all made jokes about will and
everything and stuff and then when
someone sees that and stuff like that
they see that over and over and again
there's some stuff that you know i i i
saw
a couple of weeks two weeks back a week
back there was an interview about him
and i think was talking with gayle king
and was talking about not on we were
open about this [ __ ] we don't know what
the relationship that they have we don't
know we don't know
right we don't know the relationship
that they had so we don't know what the
hell was going on with that you know
there's a lot of people in a lot of
things that you know we we want to see
everything about relationships and we
want everybody to post things about
relationships but we don't really know
what's going on we don't know what they
are talking about and we don't know that
it doesn't matter if they had an open
talk with everybody at the red table and
you were there
and when these things happen you don't
know what is the thing that and and the
the the the
the understanding that they have between
each other you don't we weren't there we
weren't there so all those jokes and
that's what it says a lot about one
another thing men vulnerability
man he was vulnerable what we did with
that
we laughed at will
we let we made fun we made memes and
stuff like that and then you wonder why
men don't want to open up about anything
about that but that digress again
all that to say there's so much a man
can take and if the whole night he was
talking [ __ ] i can understand real sense
man i don't feel he should have [ __ ]
him up like i wouldn't have [ __ ] him
up i would have waited for the thing to
happen or i would have rolled on a
[ __ ] face to face and would have
talked but
because you know on camera and
everything and stuff unfortunately
that's assault but i do understand where
will is coming from will left oscars yes
it's real
will just won an oscar
congratulations will
what do you want me to say at this point
okay i would have i'm gonna say i was
just saying i just thought that was
beautiful that this man
slapped a [ __ ] handed an l
i got a dumb i got a dub but that's a
wonderful thing and overall i think he
holds an l i disagree with most your
take only because yes my boy went from i
am legend to i am cook
i got nothing for you mars yes can you
imagine this man that sometimes used to
be called hitch
no i'm looking at him like
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
no
that was hits i was hitch the seduction
expert no i'm looking at him like
[ __ ]
yeah
it's we don't know about people's
relationship if you go outside and you
broadcast all the details of your
relationship you make a red table talk
where you're like this is what's like on
the inside of our life you invite that
judgment you invite those memes you
invite all that insults you invite that
ridicule nobody asked y'all to talk
about august and do all this stuff
that's you you guys decided to have your
little couples talking from everybody
what happens afterwards that's your
problem stupid you don't like them jokes
they keep your mouth shut about your
personal life i am very much respectful
of how people really handle their family
and their relationship life provided to
keep it in private and that's why you
monetize your relationship issues do not
get surprised if people come at it with
all their takes y'all don't hear about
my personal relationship you don't hear
about his personal relationship he don't
be out here doing all these [ __ ] red
table talks with his girl so who you
ought to talk about anybody significant
other i don't bring my mom on the show
talk some [ __ ] about my mom then we got
an issue it's a different ball game
i just explained will side i said i
understand how he might have feel sure
now also what i also said this [ __ ]
and if you make a parallel with whatever
the [ __ ] happened with the other two
groupers
over there i waited for them at the end
of the day the only reason i jumped and
i was like let's go is because they
challenge me
other than that it wouldn't you can't
just catch him in the street no no i i
said that already yeah i can't just roll
up on a [ __ ] that's a
will that would be ruining my bad you
know i disagree with you on the
vulnerability thing
because we make fun of even women who
are here being vulnerable if they say
goofy stuff we made fun of jadah yeah
personally or gusto it's not when men
come out at least not in this instance i
don't think when he said what he said on
those things i don't think it's because
it's a man being vulnerable that we left
we just laughed because he was seeing
some goofy ass [ __ ] and being vulnerable
fair because jada was saying some goofy
ass [ __ ] too and we
[ __ ] ran through her fair so to
me that's like my disappearance i think
karen's are mad they always mad but you
know what else is mad march and we're in
the middle of march madness as we speak
it's time for you to shoot your shot and
score big with my bookie it doesn't
matter whether you're filling out
multiple brackets betting on the
national championship winner or you're
simply looking for players and game
props my bookie has you covered sign up
to my bookie and use promo code abba to
secure a first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars it's simple you put in
200 you get to play with 300. you get
that you see the math you put in 200 but
you get to play with three just use
promo code abba and claim your bonus you
already gonna do this why not get some
free money on us go ahead so whether
it's college basketball nba ufc it
doesn't matter my bookie has you covered
for all your needs and with choices from
thousands of odds and lines you can turn
any day into a paid day that's my
bookies you feel me i i have zero
sympathy for will you know and you know
there's a transition of will's public
image he went from the fresh prince that
view in terms of the black community and
most folks like he was that guy then the
red table talk and the messiness with
jada started coming out everyone's like
i don't want to be anything like him and
he became the butt of most jokes and i'm
sure it eats at him i'm trying to eat
that but bro you brought it on yourself
you wanted to be the guru you wanted to
open the curtains and show what's going
on behind closed doors well guess what
turns out your closet is [ __ ] messy
yeah
yeah
your girl she ain't left the matrix
she's still plugged into some other
[ __ ] universe because we don't know
what she's thinking and she coming out
weird in every episode
she's saying crazy stuff
entanglement what well guess what [ __ ]
will you an entanglement too might be a
legal one
so you get no sympathy for me zero none
as far as them clowning your wife well
guess what that's what chris rock is
paid to do at the oscars you don't get a
pass will you don't just say yo keep my
wife's name out your mouth then don't
show up to the show stupid
don't show up
you guys don't want to get rusted by the
community don't show up don't open it
like i don't know i just don't
understand folks who want to live this
online public life make all the details
of their personal life public things
that nobody asked for or pride into you
know i have a problem with paparazzi
being invasive taking photos into
people's homes doing all this stuff i
agree that's [ __ ] unacceptable if you
out there posing for them and then say
oh my god they treat me terribly get the
[ __ ] out of my face
and don't eat from the table then leave
the table and say i don't know why why
anybody would be there the people serve
the food [ __ ] you was at the table
eating i'm gonna tell you let me tell
you this all right without what i did
what i did just there was explaining how
will felt and i can understand how we
feel
you understand what i'm saying i
understand all that but everything you
said was everything you said
that slap
is something you should have dealt with
your wife because
she put you in that situation
and she put herself in that situation
and she's the one talking about you and
them and all that
i think phil did something wrong
undoubtedly so he looks stupid he looks
like somebody who can't take a joke and
i'm like well you don't like taking
jokes you don't like being ridiculed or
criticized don't be in the public eye
and if you don't like the joke wait for
the [ __ ] to challenge you in a
boxing match yeah it's not like
[ __ ] are looking at a regular
ass relationship and then criticizing
you in ways that are not justified like
y'all are weird
you guys are saying weird [ __ ] and you
think it's weird judging by your
reactions to what your wife be saying in
the interview so don't sit here and then
acting crazy like
no y'all brought this on yourselves
something it's like i said that's
something that you have to definitely
take with your wife yeah cause all that
[ __ ] and the reason why you're there and
everything and stuff
yeah
it's
oof
your wife you're white like you want you
want you you want
people to take
your name's wife out their mouth
but your wife is always talking about
you
always
it's your wife that should stop talking
about you right now not chris rock
but you know you're going to sleep it
off and you're going to be super pissed
off and everything and stuff and i
understand i understand oh you guys
they'll come out with this pr answer you
have questions
but i'm not going to lie man chris was
having one of the roughest sets of
comedians after yeah after that slap he
said keep my wife's name out your
[ __ ] mouth chris started thinking
like do you want to keep going these
punch lines i might get mad smacked
again chris chris rock even though
everyone said he kept a good poker face
[ __ ] looked like he was fighting
back tears it's like when your mom slaps
the [ __ ]
hey there's a great philosopher that
said it the best
everybody got a plan to get hit in the
mouth
mike tyson now the beauty of
documentaries because they make you when
you watch when you feel smart
like you watch the like you know like
you read a book or something
but all you really did was get high and
watch netflix
so here we go
here we go
the documentaries the nominees are let's
just go to the nominees
oh man well you just got decked in the
mouth that's awkward that's awkward
that's so [ __ ] awkward but anyways
that's the gist of it i'm sure will
smith will be coming out tomorrow with
an apology about this because he knows
what he does wrong from a pr standpoint
yeah and he's a pr dude uh but yeah
that's a weird ass family anything else
you want to say that's a weird ass
family there you go let us know what you
guys think in the comments below
hey
don't put your [ __ ] out there
you don't want [ __ ] to talk
about your [ __ ]
don't put your [ __ ] out there yeah
that's a lot of [ __ ] there's a
lot of [ __ ] out there that'd be
asking weird [ __ ] out there be
asking me oh we don't see your wife we
don't see your mom we don't
no
cause you [ __ ] are weird